de gravats audard de matériaux
carbonisés et nuage de fumée les
secouristes qui fouillent les débris
depuis plus de deux jours font face à un
défi de taille
un incendie brûle sous les décombres
mais difficile d'en identifier la source
et conséquemment de l'éteindre
les recherches acharnées se poursuivent
jour et nuit à seurre side les autorités
demeurent confiantes de retrouver des
survivants d'euros l'espoir est toujours
possible selon la mairesse du comté de
miami dade parce que les décombres
contiennent des crevasses où l'air
circule mais la catastrophe aurait-elle
pu être évitée
un rapport d'ingénieur d'attentes de
2018 révèle que l'immeuble avait des
dommages structurels majeurs
il est notamment question de fissures et
d'effritement abondant sur les colonnes
et sur les murs du garage située sous le
bâtiment pour les gens qui habitent dans
le secteur
l'effondrement suscite des inquiétudes
nous est inquiétant pour être dangereux
mais plus ça va plus c'est un peu le
discours qui est en train de ressortir
les heures passent et l'anxiété des
familles grandi puisque des centaines de
personnes manquent toujours à l'appel
chandelle fleurs et photos ont été
placées près du bâtiment à la fois pour
honorer les personnes qui ont perdu la
vie dans les décombres mais aussi pour
soutenir ceux qui cherchent
désespérément un proche ici et me
lemieux radio canada montréal